you know having enough energy
to be able to do things like exercise
get your work done is so vitally
important and i think most people could
always use more energy so the question
is why would someone be tired in the
first place okay and the key with this
reestablishing your energy is to
really address the real cause now this
video is about nutrient deficiencies but
there are many other causes of fatigue
one being a lack of sleep
if you're not sleeping i don't care how
many vitamins you take or what you eat
you're still going to be tired and the
other core reason why people are tired
is they're consuming the wrong fuel
they're consuming too much glucose and
not running off their stored fat burning
fat is the most efficient source of your
energy you have way more sustained fuel
burning fat than you do
sugar running your body off sugar
glucose is going to be a roller coaster
up and down up and down you're not going
to have that sustained
energy and then of course the majority
of people need stimulants to keep them
energetic like caffeine coffee and when
a lot of people are tired what do they
turn to they eat food for energy of
course the food that they're eating
makes them tired so let's dive into the
nutrient deficiencies the primary ones
that can make you tired now the first
three nutrients relate to the formation
and the production
of red blood cells now without enough of
the red blood cells or the quality of
red blood cells you can't carry oxygen
and oxygen is needed to help you burn
fuel much like a car needs oxygen mixed
with gasoline right so you have a spark
plug and a carburetor you mix a certain
amount of oxygen and it ignites and
gives you energy
same thing in your body you need oxygen
to oxidize
the fuel so the first one is b12 now the
trace mineral that's involved with b12
is cobalt okay so cobalt is a necessary
trace minerals so the food that you're
eating doesn't have
cobalt it's going to be very low in b12
the best source of b12 is
animal products okay so this is a clue
that your body is telling you of what
type of diet is best for you so if
there's a classification of foods that
are missing a certain nutrient maybe our
bodies weren't designed to live off that
specific food now they might have other
nutrients but b12 is mostly in animal
products
however certain microbes can make b12 so
that's an exception so if someone's
deficient in b12 they're going to be
tired they're going to have a lot of
other problems with their nervous system
and there's a whole list of things but
they will become anemic
so what foods are high in b12
meats
fish
eggs
things like that one of the reasons why
someone might be deficient in b12 is
that they're not consuming animal
products or maybe they have an
autoimmune problem in their stomach
there's a certain
um
factor it's called an intrinsic factor
that helps you absorb b12 and if that's
not working you're going to become
anemic all right the second nutrient
that has a lot to do with the creation
of a red blood cell is
folate okay
folate is vitamin b9 and you need folate
for a lot of different things including
protection of your dna
but you also need it to make the red
blood cell so if you're deficient in
folate
you will be tired there's some
interesting reasons why people are
deficient in folate one is the tanning
booth
if you're getting too much artificial
tanning and there's too much uv that can
create a deficiency of folate now folate
is in a lot of foods but it's especially
in the dark leafy greens even the
derivation of folate comes from the word
which means leaf okay as in dark leafy
green vegetables so if you're deficient
in folate you're going to have fatigue
lethargy and you're going to be weak and
there's certain types of anemia that
involve a folate deficiency okay the red
blood cells need b12
they need folate and they need you
guessed it iron okay now the best source
of iron is not from leafy greens it's
not from spinach despite what popeye
told you the best
bioavailable source of iron is in red
meat iron is at the core of something
called hemoglobin hemoglobin is the
thing that carries oxygen in the red
blood cell okay it's like the protein
part and it not only carries oxygen it
helps you eliminate carbon dioxide so
those two have to be in a perfect ratio
so if someone is a vegan they might have
a lot of folate but they might not have
b12
and a good source of iron all right
number four
thymine or b1 now i've done some really
extensive
videos on b1 in its importance for your
brain
importance in your mood it gets rid of
anxiety and that nervous tension and
also anything that has to do with
nerve inflammation neuritis it seems to
handle that very well especially if you
have peripheral neuropathy which is this
this neurological problem at the bottom
of your feet usually which occurs
because your blood triggers are not
correct but you can think about b1 as
like a spark plug
for your energy without b1 you can't
ignite this
fuel so b1 is very very
vital in the creation of energy in your
body and if someone does a
high carb diet especially a high sugar
refined carbohydrate diet
the need for b1 goes way way way up and
they're usually deficient so they're
usually tired because they cannot burn
that fuel so that fuel just gets
converted to fat and cholesterol and
triglycerides b1 is in a lot of
different foods it's in animal products
it's in
plant products it's in seeds it's in
nuts it's in
sunflower seeds it's made by microbes as
in nutritional yeast but the reason why
most people are deficient in b1 is that
they're consuming a lot of refined
carbohydrates and sugars and so it's not
necessarily a lack of getting b1 from
the diet it's eating things that are
creating the deficiency okay so we have
b12
folate iron
b1 and number five magnesium okay
magnesium is a is crucial it's vital to
generating energy because you need
magnesium to make atp which is the
energy currency of your body and without
magnesium you can't make atp and by the
way the majority of the population is
deficient in magnesium well where do you
get magnesium well magnesium is at the
heart of chlorophyll which is in the
leafy greens it's in the vegetable
family so but you can also get magnesium
and a lot of other foods animal products
and plant-based products is good without
the refined foods and those foods that
turn into the wrong type of fuel very
fast as in grains so even though grains
might have a lot of b1
and magnesium and other minerals like
iron
it's locked up with phytic acid okay but
when they refine the grain
all the nutrition is lost and so now
you're eating this empty carbohydrate
which then creates a deficiency of these
nutrients and this is why people get
tired and number six potassium potassium
is needed in large quantities in our
body for a reason because in all of our
cells
we have
this little uh pump it's called a sodium
potassium pump
that helps you generate energy within
your muscles
and your nervous system so if you're
deficient in potassium you are going to
be tired you're going to be dragging
you're not going to have the muscle
energy you're going to try to work out
and you just don't have the endurance
not to mention the nervous system i'm
also talking about your brain and
nervous system too so if you do a lot of
um mental work um through the day you'll
lose your mental and your cognitive
power
so where do we have potassium leafy
greens but it's also in a lot of other
foods as well so as you can see we need
a combination of foods
to eat to generate energy and then we
want to avoid certain foods that make us
tired
and we want to make sure we get enough
sleep now if you haven't been sleeping
that well
that could be fatigue so i put that
video up right here check it out
you